the world's best guides to non-fiction
books come from our sponsor short form
short form offers comprehensive coverage
to thousands of top non-fiction books so
you can learn more faster unlike other
summary Services their guides provide
valuable insights counter arguments and
analyzes for a well-rounded
understanding of the topic try it free
and get 25 off using my link below
I'd like to start today with Law and
Order or law and auto depending on your
preference I know that it feels like
just yesterday that the failed former
president Donald Trump went from being a
once indicted president to a twice
indicted former president but we are now
potentially inching up imminently on
Donald Trump's third arrest and
indictment and potentially even fourth
arrest and indictment there is a very
interesting report from NBC News five or
six Secret Service agents have testified
before the January 6 grand jury sources
say it is not known what the agent's
proximity to Trump was on January 6th or
what information they may have provided
through the grand jury it's important to
remember that and it's hard to keep
track of I admit if you're busy working
listen I work in doing this and it's
hard to keep track of all of the
investigations and potential arrests
that are forthcoming involving the a
failed former president
if you have like a real job I can only
imagine that it is a mess of confusion
what is going on Donald Trump has been
arrested and indicted at the state level
in New York Donald Trump has been
arrested and indicted federally related
to the classified documents Fiasco there
is a concurrent federal investigation
into Donald Trump's role related to the
January 6th riots so while that is going
on we also have to remember what's going
on in Georgia with Bonnie Willis so
let's go through the possible
forthcoming arrests I I don't really
know which one we would call the third
or the fourth what I mean by that is we
don't exactly know which is likely to
happen first or next but the next
federal arrest would be related to the
house committee investigation into the
January 6 Trump riots those
investigations led to criminal referrals
to the justice department federal
charges remember
and they relate to allegations belief
the suggestion that Donald Trump
attempted to incite an Insurrection
participated in a conspiracy to defraud
the United States obstructed official
proceedings conspiracy to make false
statements Etc all of that has been
referred to the justice department for
potential Federal prosecution that's
what this is all about the Secret
Service agents that testified
the subject matter presumably about
which they were asked and testified all
relates to a concurrent special counsel
investigation by Jack Smith Jack Smith
is the same special prosecutor involved
in Trump's existing Federal indictment
this may be a second Federal indictment
spokeswoman for the secret service has
so far declined to comment
the content of the subpoenas and
appearances is not known
Secret Service agents who were close to
Trump on January 6th may be able to
confirm deny or provide more details on
that story first told by Cassidy
Hutchinson you of course remember her
explosive testimony under oath by the
way under oath we then get to the
potential fourth arrest the fourth
arrest would come out of Fulton County
Georgia this is the arrest the
investigation rather being handled by
the district attorney fonnie Willis and
this relates to Trump's attempt to
overturn the results in Georgia remember
that Joe Biden won Georgia in the sense
that he received more votes than Donald
Trump I know that now and you know for
all of the attacks from the ride about
post-modern leftists where words no
longer have meaning what we mean by
Trump lost and Biden won is that Biden
received more votes in concurrence with
the will of the voters of Georgia it's
not super complicated he won in this
sense that he got more votes than Trump
that's where Trump's famous phone call
where he said I need 11 000 votes give
me a break that entire Fiasco is the
subject matter of the Georgia
investigation from which a fourth arrest
could come a special grand jury heard
evidence in that case for roughly seven
months and
um there were a dozen or so indictments
recommended it was hinted at by that
zany and kooky jury 4 person that Trump
may be among those recommended
indictments we will uh see probably
during that session of the grand jury
the the grand jury term from July 11th
to September 1st that is the time range
during which we would expect that arrest
so as we continue to see
that nobody else in the 2024 Republican
primary seems to be able to make any
progress Chris Christie as as we said
yesterday tongue-in-cheek Chris
Christie's polling has surged 150
percent from one percent to 2.5 percent
but DeSantis Ron de sanctimonious he's
flat
um Nikki Haley four percent you know
everybody's flat and Trump is
essentially flat as well nobody seems to
be able to make any progress against
Trump despite now two arrests would a
third arrest damage Trump would a fourth
arrest damage Trump increasingly my
guess is that the answer is no we may
find out about that soon let's now talk
about an explosive development remember
Law and Order folks Law and Order you've
got to have law you've got to have order
explosive development in Trump's
existing Federal indictment CNN has
obtained the audio of Donald Trump in
2021 talking about classified documents
that he has this audio which I am going
to play for you
contradicts many of Donald Trump's
recent claims during interviews about
classified documents it also contradicts
Trump's claims that he Declassified
everything while President remember this
is one of the arguments well I can't
possibly get in trouble for what I did
with classified documents after leaving
office because I Declassified all of it
if that were the case we wouldn't have
Trump on an audio recording saying these
are classified because he would have
Declassified them CNN exclusive CNN
obtains the tape of Trump's 2021
conversation about classified documents
let's just play it this first aired last
night on Anderson Cooper's program it is
extraordinary and at the top level it is
notable for two reasons number one it
exposes Trump's crimes number two it
exposes Trump's lies and of course they
are in many cases interwoven bad sick
people but that was your coup you know
that
they were trying to do that before you
even were sworn in that's right trying
to overthrow your life well with Millie
uh let me see that I'll show you an
example he said that I wanted to attack
Iran
isn't it amazing I have a big pile of
papers this thing just came out look
this was him
they presented me this is off the Record
okay so Trump first says this is off the
Record that's not indicative of anything
related to the classification status of
the documents so far no issue let's
continue
they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
wow we looked at some this was him this
wasn't done by me this was him and all
sorts of stuff it's Pages wrong
wait a minute let's see here
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly conversation
this is secret information look at this
you look back and Hillary would print
that out all the time
I should send it to Anthony Weiner yeah
by the way is that incredible yeah I was
just saying because we're talking about
it and you know he said he wanted to
attack Iran
this was done by the military given to
me
um I think we can probably guess what
we'll have to see yeah we'll have to try
to figure out as president I could have
did last year that is critical that is
critical I can't you know but this is
yes
Trump said as president I could have
Declassified it and a staffer says yeah
and laughs and then Trump says now I
can't you know but this is still a
secret why would you say you could have
Declassified something if you did
declassify all the documents there
whether Trump is now claiming he
telepathically Declassified whether
Trump is claiming that there was any
default declassification that happens
when he takes something it doesn't
matter what mechanism he cites for
declassification as bogus as those
methods may be he says right here this
is still Secret
I could have Declassified it but now I
can't let's listen to the last few
seconds
is that interesting yeah it's so cool
and you probably almost didn't believe
me but now you believe me no I believe
it's incredible right yeah they bring
some bring some Cokes in please so there
Trump calls for sodas uh calls for Cokes
to be brought in to sort of celebrate
the disclosure of classified documents
to people who are not clear to do that
so this is extraordinarily damning this
is going to be uh an exhibit for sure in
the forthcoming either criminal trial of
trump or something that will be
presented by prosecutors at possible
plea negotiations to say look at what we
have we've got you you might be better
off taking a plea now not only is it
abundantly clear that this is part of
the criminality it's also important to
understand that Trump with absolutely no
hesitation whatsoever no qualms No No
Reservations at all regularly lies about
this stuff here is Donald Trump in that
whacked out interview last week on Fox
news with Brett Bayer
um which was covered while I was away
saying there was nothing to declassify
because these were newspaper stories and
and articles uh that he had and was
showing people but of course we know
that that is a lie here is Trump with a
totally straight face as straight as
Trump's face can be uh lying to Brett
Baier
document Brad there was no document that
was a massive amount of papers and
everything else talking about Iran and
other things and it may have been held
up or may not but that was not a
document I didn't have a document per se
there was nothing to declass with these
were newspaper stories magazine stores
okay it is abundantly clear folks I mean
I know that we on the left have a
problem and the problem is when we see
something like this we say this is it
folks we've there is nothing that these
people can come up with now to explain
this away and then they come up with
something they go no Trump misspoke here
or he misspoke their Trump thought the
document was classified but it really
wasn't it was just Trump mistake
they will always have some way to try to
weasel out of it but we don't care about
that what we care about is what is going
to happen in a court of law because
these are now legal proceedings these
are legal proceedings Trump says to
Brett Bayer I these weren't classified
documents in that conversation remember
that interview was before the audio
leaked the interview was pre-audio leak
Trump says I was showing people
newspaper articles in the audio
recording released by CNN Trump is
clearly referring to documents from the
Department of Defense he's not saying
look at what they wrote In The New York
Times or whatever he's clearly referring
to government documents and he knows
that they are classified
that he didn't declassify them as
president that he can no longer
declassify them as an ex-president and
that it is not something that he should
be showing people this is evidence of
exactly the criminality
with which Donald Trump has been charged
make sure you subscribe to the YouTube
channel my friends in may we had more
than three million people watch our
clips
but not subscribe if just 10 of that 3
million subscribes right now we will get
to the two million dollar assuming 2
million subscriber uh line on YouTube
very very strongly and quickly uh we'll
take a quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors is short form short
form makes the world's best guides to
non-fiction books and not only does
short form Summarize each non-fiction
book itself into key points that you can
cover in just a few minutes they have
all sorts of interactive exercises to
help you apply the ideas to what you've
read to retain more the guide to each
book also includes intellectual insights
comparing and contrasting the book to
other prominent books about the same
topic so that you can contextualize the
book and understand the controversies
and the disagreements they also have
books across every non-fiction genre
from economics and politics to science
and health I was recently checking out
James clear's Atomic habits on short
form of course they have the guide but
they also have highlights they also
include other similar books about habits
and developing a routine with
differences and similarities super super
useful and a lot more than just a summer
of the book there are new guides and
articles released every week and short
form is giving my audience a free trial
plus 25 off a subscription which is a 50
value so for the price of a book per
month you get access to thousands go to
shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below all right many of you wrote in
about my coverage yesterday of Bobby
Kennedy Junior's candidacy the reactions
were all over the map people saying
David you're wrong this is God's gift to
politics or David you're wrong he's way
worse than what you're saying he
actually has no redeeming qualities and
you're not being tough enough on Bobby
Kennedy Jr maybe because you know him I
know him I sat with him at dinner once
um and then people who said I
appreciated you giving some context
about Bobby Kennedy Jr I want to be
super clear the negatives about Bobby
Kennedy Jr are single-handedly
disqualifying of him as an even remotely
serious presidential candidate and I'm
going to give you examples today so I'm
not going to be wishy-washy and act like
well there's pros and cons and maybe
they cancel out so maybe you'll vote for
the guy no what I'm telling you is
although there are some things about him
that I like
there are concerns so bad that they are
uniquely disqualifying I'm going to give
you one example okay tonight tonight
Bobby Kennedy Jr is hosting a so-called
Health policy Roundtable you can RSVP
and participate if you want okay
this health policy Roundtable is being
held with dangerous vectors of
disinformation many of whom we've
covered on the program already these are
not just you know folks with slightly
different views about vaccination or
whatever these are dangerous and in some
cases seemingly certifiably insane
lunatics and hosting a health policy
Roundtable with these people
is single-handedly disqualifying take a
look at this Mr Kennedy will meet with
leading critics of prevailing Health
policy including Dr Joe Mercola Dr
Sherry Tenpenny Dr Pierre Corey Dr
Patrick gentempo Maureen McDonnell Dell
big tree Mickey Willis and Sayer G let's
go back to Sherry 10 penny in a moment
okay these people
many of whom we've talked about before
Joseph Mercola is a widely known
purveyor of pseudoscience and conspiracy
theories fined by the FDA for making
false and misleading claims about his
products and covid-19 treatments
dangerous not a serious person okay
Pierre Corey advocates for the use of
ivermectin as a coveted treatment or
cure despite the fact that there's no
actual randomized controlled trials
showing that that works
um Patrick gentempo chiropractor and
entrepreneur who made an anti-vaxx
documentary that's who Bobby Kennedy is
meeting with uh Maureen McDonald
holistic health educator who is
anti-vaxx and spreads false information
about vaccines every single one of these
people Dell big tree founded an
anti-vaccine group produces propaganda
movies
Mickey Willis activist who also promotes
uh vaccine disinformation has been
denounced by serious medical ex okay so
all of these people and then of course
Sherry Tenpenny if the name Sherry
Tenpenny rings a bell it's because we've
talked about her before here is
self-described vaccine expert Sherry
Tenpenny explaining that this year
this year folks it's almost July and it
hasn't happened this year
every one of us will have five or even
10 people we know Dead from the vaccine
now we're seeing the tsunami of deaths
that I've been talking about since the
beginning of 21 right millions of people
are going to die you know when Judy
mikovitz came out on pandemic at the
beginning of that and said that
that more than 50 million people are
going to die and everybody was like whoa
and when they started interviewing me
and I and asked me what did I think
about that number I said it's way too
low
it's going to be much more than 50
million people in America alone
and we're already starting to see it
we're not so the tsunami of deaths is
coming it's already here and I believe
that remember Bobby Kennedy Jr is having
an event tonight with this woman as if
she is an expert on health what's
happening now and is is starting to
happen now is the tsunami of regret
of the people that fell for the lies
your friends and family members and
parents and children and all they did to
your grandchildren just could not be
told otherwise
but now that people are dying like flies
I mean my business partner has 83 close
people in his life that have died I
don't even believe her business partner
has 83 close people in his life never
mind 83 people that have died 83.
it's the beginning
and I predict that by the end of this
year every person in this room and every
and every person listening
to a minimum of five probably ten or
more close friends and family members
that have died from these shots okay I
still we're almost in July now I
understand we've got half of the year
left I don't know a single person that's
died of the vaccine and everybody I know
is vaccinated that's who Bobby Kennedy
is having an event with one more Sherry
10 Penny clip just to really drive home
how insane this is uh here she says that
it's a vaccinating kids as a form of
child sacrifice this is happening in
America people right and it's your job
to stop everybody you know and wake them
up and shove it in their face and if
they defund you off of social media who
cares now it's about trying to save
unborn babies and pregnant women it's
about the they they now are actually
starting a trial and to give these shots
to six month olds
this is child sacrifice this is the
Resurgence of child sacrifice from the
days of the Babylonian Mystery Schools
yeah and then she goes into a religious
nonsense all right folks so listen uh I
think it's great that Bobby Kennedy
wants a higher minimum wage and wants to
deal with homelessness and whatever this
event this event is uniquely
disqualifying
let's dig in now a little more into his
view on vaccines
um Bobby Kennedy Jr recently appeared on
Bill Maher's podcast the clubhouse
we now have the opportunity to hear
directly from him what is his view about
vaccines Bill Maher confronted him not
really Bill Maher told him I basically
agree with you about vaccines but you're
not handling this correctly you're gonna
have to defend your position so we now
have video of Bobby Kennedy explaining
his views on vaccines he always says I'm
not anti-vaxx I just want safe vaccines
but you will very quickly see in this
video that his views are simply not
based in fact let's get right into it on
the side that shows that autism is
caused by vaccines there's over 100
studies
I in fact did a book in which I listed
all of those studies
and digested in other words summarize
them all and you can go and Source them
and I have okay this is a classic
anti-vaxx line there's a hundred studies
that find a link between vaccines and
autism there's a hundred studies and
people accept it uncritically the folks
that have fallen for this who by the way
are mostly right-wing folks it's a whole
interesting thing Trump is now praising
Bobby Kennedy Jr his constituency is
heavily made up of Maga people he should
probably be running as a republican
quite frankly but let's not do someone
like Bobby goes 100 studies link
vaccines to autism and then someone
hears it and repeats it uh you can
actually investigate that okay there is
not any scientific evidence that links
vaccines to autism and in fact on the
contrary many Studies have found no link
whatsoever the foremost such quote study
by now disbarred doctor
revoked medical license Andrew Wakefield
was retracted it's a bogus study most of
the data that many people cite comes
from that but let's talk about this
hundred studies thing the claim that
more than 100 studies link vaccines to
autism is based on a list of papers that
was compiled by an anti-vaxx website
they have a horse in the game in the
race so to speak and the list has been
widely debunked by experts now don't
take my word for it do what Bobby says
go and look at the list but don't just
look at the summaries that he makes look
at the actual uh citations okay many of
the papers on the list aren't actually
about vaccines and autism at all they
might be about one or the other some
have been retracted some have
methodological flaws and some simply
theorize about what could cause autism
if you look at those hundred papers you
will find papers that for example say
when we think about why there may be
rising rates of autism one reason could
be that we are better at diagnosing it
so we're actually just identifying more
cases of autism another reason could be
vaccines another reason could be you
know whatever Wi-Fi right just because
you put vaccines on a list of things
that hypothetically could be related
doesn't mean that it's a study that
shows it this is the sort of stuff he's
citing tons of examples there's one
paper called a positive Association
found
between Autism prevalence and childhood
vaccination and it claims to show that
there's a correlation between
vaccination rates and autism in
different states the idea being states
with more vaccination also have more
autism the problem is it doesn't
establish any causal link it's not
science it doesn't account for the fact
that autism diagnosis is likely better
in the very same states that have more
vaccination I'll give you an example and
I don't want to beat a dead horse here
uh I apologize for the the the violent
term beating a dead horse but it's it's
really important to understand this
think about the states that have higher
rates of vaccination
okay think about the states that have
better health infrastructure
okay if you think about those States
California New York Connecticut
Massachusetts
states that have better health
infrastructure are going to find and
diagnose more autism because they
actually have protocols for when
teachers observe certain behaviors you
would actually say hey this is someone
who maybe should be screened for autism
etc those are the same states that have
higher vaccination rates due to Better
Health infrastructure and better
education so this is just one example
and you can go through and you can find
it it's a bogus list on the also
important to note the very pediatrician
that Bobby Kennedy cites for much of his
anti-vaccine views has disavowed Bobby
Kennedy and says he interviewed me once
and then completely misstated all the
stuff I said
that's another Classic on the other hand
we have the work of the CDC uh National
Academy of Medicine all these groups
that say we we've looked at it we find
absolutely no link between vaccines and
autism okay it gets crazier from there
let's continue remember this is Bobby
Kennedy in his own words giving us his
view about vaccine says 100 studies find
a link that's a debunked list many of
the studies don't even actually deal
with that issue let's continue over 450
uh
450 studies summarize and I have 1400
citations the questions for your
campaign is I'm not talking about this
stuff on my campaign I'm just talking
between you and that's a ridiculous
Assumption of course you're going to
have to talk about YouTube somebody
asked me I'm going to they're all going
to ask you are you seriously we're going
to ask you about the you think they're
there for your friends who want to help
you no they're going they don't want
anything they want to go to the most
vulnerable point which is your that's
because you don't believe in vaccines
that's not me talking no I don't believe
I I believe you are more
um
I just believe in science I I understand
but you know any genre of the science
yeah but let's not talk about again the
science that's the thing that's the
mistake they made I believe in science
let me just say this we have different
every medicine is required to duplicate
controlled trials that's what science is
you give you you give a group of people
a cohorted people the medicine
and then you give the pla a simile
situation situated cohort of people the
placebo
and then you look at Health outcomes
over a four or five year period because
many of the impact of the outcomes
are going to have long diagnostic
Horizons along incubation periods so you
won't see them immediately you need to
do it Anthony found you just said eight
years for vaccine
you need to watch them for a while
those Studies have not the only medicine
that never gets tested are vaccines okay
so let's talk about that this they
believe that this is their sort of trump
card right that this is irrefutable he
says we we need these placebo-controlled
vaccine trials this is a common ruse
with these folks okay it is true that
the specific autism vaccine link has not
been extensively explored with regard to
child vaccinations through that
particular type of type of trial but why
not the why not is extraordinarily
important to understand the reason is
similar to why we don't do randomized
controlled trials about smoking while
pregnant right you could say listen I
don't know that smoking while pregnant
is actually bad in order to say smoking
while pregnant Is bad we should take a
thousand women we should have a hundred
not smoke at all we should have a
hundred smoke a pack a day and a hundred
smoke two packs a day okay and then we
spend 20 years seeing what is the impact
on those kids okay that would be
horribly unethical because of what we do
know it is generally considered
unethical to withhold potentially
life-saving vaccines from individuals if
they are available and proven to be
effective the vaccines that he has been
against for a long time for kids are so
effective at preventing serious illness
that how would you do such a test do you
say hey let's volunteer a bunch of kids
to go through adolescence with no
vaccines and see what happens to them it
would be insanely unethical because of
the risk that you would expose them to
you have to balance risks and benefits
and with the serious actual validated
studies that have looked into this issue
not by doing it the way he wants because
it would be hugely unethical
but by looking at it in the ways that
the CDC and others do there has been no
link established between vaccination and
autism and this is his view so now we've
got it it's not people misstating it
it's Bobby Kennedy Jr in his own words
and it's horrifying
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
Joe Berkowitz a writer whose work has
been featured in vulture the New Yorker
Fast Company he's author of the books
American cheese and Away with words and
also of the recent article when did the
F your feelings crowd get so triggered
Joe really great having you on I
appreciate your time
thanks for having me so I mean maybe to
start you know it's it's increasingly as
the American right wing and Republican
party has gotten away from serious
policy discussions there has been more
and more of a focus on this idea of
owning the libs triggering the
snowflakes
Etc almost as a stand-in for policy
where they they almost seem to see it as
virtuous for its own sake if if Liberals
are angry then we must be doing
something right at the same time they
have this phrase facts don't care about
your feelings which often comes up in in
right-wing media Etc did this all start
because they started losing American
public opinion on policy or what are the
origins of this shift that we've seen
uh I I think
uh there is a resentment about uh not
having more standing in culture
I think
um just seeing how kind of
the liberal bias of entertainment uh I
think it's calmed down a little bit at
least but looking back at 2016 it was
pretty rampant if you look at the the
Clinton campaign you know leaning on
people like like Lena Dunham and things
like that it was just I look back now
and I can sort of see where some of the
resentment may have come from
but I do feel there's resentment of uh
from conservatives about feeling like
they didn't have a place in culture uh
and
that uh kind of LED in my opinion to the
uh trolling as politics and which you
know saw its uh hypothesis in um in the
ascent of Donald Trump in 2016. one of
the interesting
um hypocrisies is that while on the one
hand there is this F your feelings sort
of idea from the right it's that they
also engage in much of that same well
this just feels wrong sort of
argumentation just to pick one example
and there's so many right the entire
drag show stuff where children are being
recruited and forced and
groomed and it's you know for the most
part kids are showing up at any kind of
drag event if their parents have made
the choice to bring them there nobody's
being recruited nobody's being forced
but they just feel as though it's very
much wrong and we could talk about a lot
of these different arguments talk a
little bit about that and and the idea
that it is also an instance sort of of a
projection that they say uh we don't
care about your feelings we care about
facts and yet so many of the arguments
they do make are based simply on their
feelings
yeah a lot of what we're seeing now uh
is all feelings based uh backlash and I
think
um
it's it's probably
best uh exemplified by you know the uh
the the backlash to the the Bud Light
campaign and the and Target and things
like that uh I saw a tweet after my
article came out
and it was Charlie Kirk from
um Turning Point USA yeah surprisingly a
lot of cloud I guess uh yeah shockingly
people even though it's sort of Youth
centered but it seems like only old
people seem to listen to it but anyway
Charlie Kirk uh tweeted that I opened my
fridge the other day and I didn't know
whether my ketchup was woke or my
mustard was woke and it sounds like a
parody yeah but he was being 100 serious
and I think I'm not sure if I put this
in the article or not but like somebody
was saying I heard that Chick-fil-A got
a Dei uh vice president or a just a high
up person just just strictly for Dei
he's like does that mean I have to
boycott Chick-fil-A I like Chick-fil-A
and so it's this feeling like we have to
uh push back against these things even
though they're not
I mean there's no effect on your life if
uh
Bud Light sends a beer to a trans
influencer I I I really I've racked my
brain and I can't see how that affects
anyone in any ways but there is livid
outrage uh there is Kid Rock ticking an
automatic weapon and shooting a bunch of
Bud Light
which I suppose is supposed to exemplify
it's supposed to show strength I don't
know how that shows strength but anyway
and yeah so these are all feelings this
isn't a policy that they have a a
logical rebuttal to this is just
I know that in my heart that it is bad
for uh lgbtq representation to be to
appear in the corporate world doesn't
need to have a corporate sanction that
is against what I stand for and I am
furious about it in my heart
one of the um
themes with a lot of these culture
issues
is using kids as a sort of shield in a
way or not even a shield it's not a
scapegoat it's sort of like saying kids
are the victims and if you go back 10
years when I was covering the fight for
um for marriage equality you would hear
about no gay gay men are grooming kids
and they are pedophiles and so on and so
so forth now you're seeing it with trans
people now you're seeing it with the
drag shows uh when it came to masks and
vaccines it was the kids the kids can't
breathe and the vaccines aren't safe for
the kids and the kids aren't getting a
say and then it's well uh for when it
comes to don't say gay and the AP
History Class in Florida it's kids are
being taught to hate America or whatever
the case may be this is this is a theme
right I mean at this point the the use
of kids is the victims who we have to
protect seems like a clear-cut strategy
yeah
um you know with the don't say gay
initiative they promised it was just to
protect children and then of course they
did start doing it for uh middle school
and I believe high school students uh
but they did start raising the age yeah
and it was pretty clear they just wanted
to get it out of school and
I I do believe they want to protect
children but I think they're lying about
who they want to protect them from they
say they want to protect them from
predators but what I think they want to
protect them from is the possibility
that they'll think it's okay to be gay
that they that they'll learn that if
they feel as though they were born in
the wrong body that there are
possibilities to explore that they don't
they want to protect them from even a
chance of that they would rather uh have
them you know be uh suppressed
suppressed and go back to before that
was uh sanctioned culturally at all so
they want to protect them from reality
and then it's even more egregious with
the the black history stuff
um I used as an example in the piece the
idea of protecting children from
learning uh how Jackie Robinson was
treated uh when he what became the first
black major baseball player yeah but um
that may be a slightly exaggerated
example I don't even think so I mean
just the kinds of things that they want
to pretend protect children from feeling
uh weird or guilty about it's uh it's
ludicrous uh especially after all the
talk about six years ago when Trump was
first you know uh becoming present uh
about safe spaces yeah you uh they're
just uh
ill-preparing children uh from finding
out hard truth later on if they just
want to paint a whitewashed portrait of
history for them now
what do you think or do you have an
opinion when it comes to the strategy
that the left should adopt because when
it comes to a lot of these cultural
issues you can find arguments all over
the map you can find arguments that say
the the left should completely ignore
every single one of these issues you
know androgynous M M's that Tucker
Carlson's no longer attracted to it's
like just don't just don't even weigh in
don't even acknowledge that they are
doing these things another view is
fight them on each of the issues on the
merits make the case about the M Ms make
the case about AP History but like fight
it on the merits for each one third
option expose the hypocrisy as you were
talking about they claim to be about
against safe spaces but they're
essentially creating them through some
of these policies they claim to be
against feelings-based uh uh policy
proposals but it's exactly what they're
doing right so that would be like a
third option focus on the hypocrisy do
you have an opinion as to what the best
approach would be for the left on this
I remember right when uh Biden right
after the inauguration he was just uh or
at least his administration anyway was
coming out with uh
fulfilling campaign promises left and
right they were just kind of heads down
getting the work done and if you look
back at the Articles at that time that
was when uh
Eminems are woke
and what was it oh yeah the Dr Seuss
books that was just the
those were the major issues and they
were ignored uh in favor of passing
legislation or there was just no
messaging on the left really about it
and that seemed to work but that's not
an election that's just getting stuff
done I think last year uh the midterms
they were set up to be a referendum on a
lot of these uh culture War type issues
true and I think in addition to having
weak candidates I think what we've
learned is that a lot of people who
aren't on Twitter for the entirety of
the day or listening to whatever is to
the right of Fox News oan or Newsmax or
whatever
those people don't care about that stuff
or
and I think or at least a majority seem
to have you know bigger concerns uh you
know like
inflation seemed to be abandoned for
Trans athletes in a lot of these
campaigns
um
so I do think
um that a good strategy I've seen a
couple politicians
uh do this is just kind of
point out how weird this stuff is like
uh I forget which state I should have
prepared a little bit but uh either
Tennessee or just some one state wanted
to have genital inspections oh yeah
student athletes to make sure uh that
they're uh they're the uh gender they
were assigned at Birth
and that's that's pretty creepy
especially for the people who are
constantly pointing out like beware of
creepy people like
um so yeah I think uh
trying to debate that might be a losing
issue because you're not going to
dissuade someone from from uh their
claims that that trans people shouldn't
have rights or uh black history
shouldn't be taught in schools you can't
dissuade someone about that you can't
defeat them doesn't matter if you have
the facts uh
people you're not going to convince
someone who's uh livelihood depends on
on being confidently wrong so just point
out how weird it is and move on that
seems to be a winning strategy for uh
some politicians I've seen I I certainly
agree with that at least from what I've
seen so far we've been speaking with Joe
Berkowitz about his article when did the
F your feelings crowd get so triggered
we're going to be linking to the article
Joe I really appreciate your time and
insights today
well thanks for adding me on David it
was a pleasure
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show we thought
it might be happening and it very
clearly is happening Donald Trump is
scared to debate his fellow Republican
challengers in the 2024 Republican
presidential primary he is now using the
cover of saying Fox News is no longer a
fair place for him to have a debate as a
part of the story he is telling about
why he will likely not participate at
least in the first Republican primary
debate scheduled for August 23rd on Fox
News let's be super earlier and just
call this for what it is Trump doesn't
believe that debating will be good for
him and I have to tell you I don't know
that he is wrong he is leading the
Republican primary by quite a bit and
we're going to look at that polling in a
little bit
if the debates go well
he would still Simply Be leading the
Republican primary Maybe by a little
more but he's already winning by enough
to win the Republican primary on the
other hand if the debates don't go well
either because he stumbles or everybody
else gangs up on him make him look
stupid or they treat him unfairly
whatever
it can only hurt him and so Donald Trump
is aware of the fact that the debates
may be a risk to him given where the
polling is right now and now Donald
Trump is making this abundantly clear he
went on Newsmax yesterday he says he
doesn't know that he wants to do any
primary debates but specifically he says
Fox News Fox News is now hostile to him
and he just may not do it take a listen
then you have a heart
but it was fine I thought it was okay
but there was nothing friendly about it
you know it was nasty and I thought I
did a good job I've been given credit
for doing a good job but I've also
people said why would you do it because
it was really you know everything was
like an unfriendly it was always
everything was unfriendly no smiling no
uh let's have fun let's make America
great again everything was like a hit
so you know you have a hostile Network
and you have people that are obviously
the candidates are against you and uh
they therefore are being hustle and if
you're leading by the way isn't that
amazing he's like also the candidates
would be against me it's like well yeah
they're running against you of course
the candidates are going to be what he
wants the candidates to be for Trump on
the debate
Okay so
I mean listen reading between the lines
you don't have to read between the lines
very much Trump is saying I'm winning
now I don't really get the point it can
really only hurt me and it might
actually hurt me that is something that
actually might happen Trump then um
going on Truth social
and continuing the attacks end quote so
Fox News which is down 37 percent of the
capital R ratings doesn't cover my
getting the man of the decade award
because of my great trade policies in
Michigan or my keynote speech for Faith
and freedom in DC and then wants me to
show up and get them ratings for their
quote presidential debate where I'm
leading the field by 40 points all they
do is promote against all hope Ron de
sanctimonious and he's dropping Like a
Rock sorry Fox News life doesn't work
that way how bizarre has the American
political scene gotten Trump then
continuing to truth apoplectically quote
Fox News just covered from beginning to
the end the Rhonda sanctimonious very
boring con news conference at the
capital border but didn't cover one
minute of my two big speeches on
Saturday and Sunday night one for Faith
and freedom in DC the other about trade
in Michigan where I was presented with
the man of the decade award the Des
Sanctus speech was just a rehash of all
the things I did to have the safest and
strongest Border in U.S history also I'm
up on him by 40 points and also up big
on Biden bottom line folks Trump is
afraid to debate and it seems as though
he is not going to participate the first
debate scheduled for let's see what we
have here Politico has a guide to the
first presidential debate in the primary
the highly anticipated debate is going
to take place August 23rd at fizzerv
pfizerv Forum in Milwaukee where the RNC
is going to be held in 2024. Fox News
will host the event outline specifics on
Tuesday Brett Bayer and Martha McCallum
will be moderating
um and uh you know it's going to be on
Fox News and we'll have more information
as we get closer Trump indeed may not
debate and if that is the case I can
only imagine that his supporters will
say it is the only correct decision that
could possibly be made all right uh
Donald Trump during a deranged interview
on Newsmax praised Bobby Kennedy Jr
saying he respects them very much very
strongly respecting him they show b-roll
of Bobby Kennedy doing push-ups well
while Trump says this uh I I want to
talk about this take a listen I will say
RFK Jr who I've known not very well but
I've known for a while and I respect him
a lot of people respect him he's got
some
um
some very important points to be made no
he's a respected person yeah the least
surprising thing I would expect to hear
from Donald Trump and of course because
Bobby Kennedy Jr is running as a
Democrat it's to Trump's Advantage it's
the Trump's advantage to prop up someone
that could damage Joe Biden now let's
talk about logical fallacies okay
remember that with logical fallacies
we can interpret them strictly but
sometimes we interpret them colloquially
or a little more informally strictly
speaking if we say I'm skeptical of
Bobby Kennedy Jr because Trump's a
and if Trump likes him then there must
be something wrong with Bobby Kennedy Jr
like technically speaking that is the
logical fallacy of guilt by association
but we have to be able to distinguish
guilt by association right if I say
Hitler breathed oxygen so oxygen must be
bad that makes no sense that's idiotic
right it would be Alex Jones level for
me to say something like that on the
show I would never do it if I were to
say to you Hitler had a doctor so
therefore doctors in general shouldn't
be trusted that's silly that doesn't
make any sense you would rightly cancel
your your paid subscription to this show
if you had one which you probably don't
but if I were to say
Hitler supported Mussolini and Franco
in Italy and Spain that makes me
skeptical of Mussolini and Franco that
does make sense I would then look into
Mussolini and Franco and said oh my
instincts were right Hitler's support
was a red flag here when we look into
Bobby Kennedy Jr and we find his
questionable takes about vaccines in
Russia foreign policy the 2020 election
all of it then we say oh right the fact
that Trump respects him and is saying
positive things about him was a red flag
because it is then borne out by the
facts that we were able to find
not surprising that Trump is saying
positive things about Bobby Kennedy Jr
one other clip from this Newsmax
interview Trump attacking Fox for saying
they are backing loser DeSantis this is
getting really wild what their problem
is but they don't cover a lot of the
things that they should be covering uh
they backed a loser they backed a guy
that can't win Ronda sanctimonious I
call him he's losing by 40 points some
people say 51 points he's losing by that
and they give him so much time I watched
today they gave him a live a live
presentation down at the border which
was very boring and all he didn't say I
would use various policies and those
were all my policies so uh he boringly
said he would do all the same stuff I
already succeeded with that's it's quite
a criticism if that criticism were true
it would actually be quite damning and
yet I
all right so there is Trump uh going
after DeSantis going after Fox
everybody's bad everybody's so unfair
where I want to direct us now the final
point for this part of the show
is going to be that it actually seems
that against Joe Biden it's becoming
clear that DeSantis is the better choice
let's talk about that we have new swing
State polling and I want to be really
clear about this this is general
election swing State polling which finds
that Ron DeSantis would do better
against Joe Biden than would Donald
Trump
this does not mean the Republican magats
are going to choose someone other than
Trump to be their nominee
this doesn't mean any of that Trump is
still the most likely Republican nominee
it just means that Trump's claim that he
would beat Biden where DeSantis would
lose is not borne out by the facts why
do we care about swing States we care
about swing States because whether it's
DeSantis or Trump Joe Biden's going to
win California whether it's DeSantis or
Trump DeSantis or Trump are going to win
Wyoming okay the election is going to
come down to a group of Swing States in
those swing States we are increasingly
getting data that Ron DeSantis would do
better against Joe Biden than would
Donald Trump I'm not giving advice to
Republicans I'm just telling you this is
what the data shows if you look at a new
poll out of Pennsylvania you find that
Biden leads Trump but DeSantis leads by
it remember these are hypothetical
matchups where you say to people if it
were Trump versus Biden who do you vote
for if it were Des Sanctus versus Biden
who do you vote for and people respond
in Georgia of an important state that
Joe Biden won in 2020 unusually so for
Democrats in recent years in Georgia
Biden leads Trump but DeSantis leads
Biden in Arizona another really
important State uh Biden leads Trump but
DeSantis leads Biden let's see what else
we have from swing states that may be it
for a recent once uh oh Michigan in
Michigan Biden and Trump retired
DeSantis leads Biden very small margin
and statistically probably a dead heat
so the important takeaway here is that
the Republican electorate right now it's
June 27th right this could change Trump
gets arrested a third or fourth time
DeSantis comes up with some free pony
plan that everybody loves all of a
sudden free zebras who knows it could
change the point right now is in these
very important contested States swing
States
DeSantis is polling better than Trump
against the most likely Democratic
nominee Joe Biden
so it might be the logical thing for
Republicans to select someone with a
better shot at winning but they seem
determined to select Donald Trump we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P on the bonus show yesterday
I told stories about uh my flights out
and back from California I also talked
about of the homeless problem in San
Francisco in fact I I didn't criticize
the homeless people I said San Francisco
didn't cause homelessness the Eggman
apparently didn't like what I had to say
listen to this
hey Dave I'm just a little bit
disappointed in how you describe the
homeless people sorry these and the
camps and stuff that you saw while out
Visiting San Francisco
um personally when I see stuff like that
I go over and interact with people I
meet them I talk to them okay I drove by
the encampments uh on the way to an
event I'm sorry Eggman I didn't stop to
talk to people at the encampment I I'm
sorry I didn't do it you're right get
high with them I buy them some food I
hang out maybe they buy me some food
maybe they get mihai
um so those are just people that I want
to meet and talk to a lot more than
people on an airplane stuffing 50 bags
in an overhead I I was not stuffing 50
bags in an overhead uh I I brought on a
rollerboard and a personal item my
girlfriend brought on a rollerboard and
a personal item and then we had the
foldable baby stroller which folds right
into the over overhead and then we had a
diaper bag okay there was nothing crazy
going on dragging a kid around I mean
look I would love to hang out with you
but I would much more like to hang out
with somebody living an RV in San
Francisco all right well I'm sorry
Eggman go and drive to San Francisco and
hang out at the RV I'm sorry I failed
the Eggman when it came to the
encampments all right we've got a great
bonus show for you today I won't even
tell you what's on it because I'm
running so behind but it's a great bonus
show I encourage you to check it out
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the world's best
guides to non-fiction books come from
our sponsor short form short form offers
comprehensive coverage to thousands of
top non-fiction books so you can learn
more faster unlike other summary
Services their guides provide valuable
insights counter arguments and analyzes
for a well-rounded understanding of the
topic try it free and get 25 off using
my link below